welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley
[Music]
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r u
gerby sure is [ __ ] little show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out if they're good to be
classy or after just a big old piece of
trash
i'm your host h foley coming at you on a
beautiful day
we're down here at antootie's basement
uh-huh uh she's got wind of the patreon
she heard it's cooking she knows what's
up i was climbing over amazon packages
trying to get down the steps
i was getting some emails about some
[ __ ] uh uh some charges that went
through on the card too by the way
the thing that concerned me is i usually
do see a lot of amazon packages upstairs
at today's but
there's different people's names she
steals them she steals them yeah so
she's poor chopping yeah these are all
addressed to her which is nervous
this ain't good keep an eye on that
[ __ ] chase cart yeah
uh my co-host is coming at you from
across the table which means it's a
family episode
sure is uh he's the ceo of ru garbage
he's an international businessman
he had to be in a foxhole let me tell
you something kids this is the guy
you want next to you with the m60 feet
in the ammo
my guy kevin james ryan hey gang happy
to be here thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you rate
review subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube and as you know
those numbers are
true true to [ __ ] roof uh also
patreon.com
and as we know today found out those
numbers
doing good over there we're having a
good time those numbers are true [ __ ]
from the basement up to the first floor
second floor true to [ __ ] roof oh
yeah uh if you're not familiar sign up
for patreon you get um
you can get your uh garbage question
read you'll also get uh
bonus episodes of ayg you'll get
episodes of hard feelings which is
behind the curtains being fully [ __ ]
on each other a little hr a little good
old time a lot of fun um
and also every month we do a live stream
with the top two tier members
uh where you get to ask your questions
we ask you know we answer your questions
you ask it's all it's a whole thing it's
a fun time it's a good time we have a
couple of pops we get about [ __ ] we
get a good number of people in there and
it's a good [ __ ] hoot now
the thing that's really stinking in with
me is that uh uh the squad
we're like-minded people yeah we're
apples from the same tree there's also a
couple of
real [ __ ] dirt bags in that thing too
i forget his name with that dude that
collects toys yikes
[Laughter]
it's a good squad yeah uh real that dude
smokes newports in his house
in the toy room yeah uh real quick bit
of business as you notice uh it's a it's
a single shot today
uh our good friend t-bone it's hemmed up
right now
uh he'll be back next week um we love
him and we'll uh
yeah yeah yeah shout out to t-bone uh
kids hemmed up but
you know moving forward there's no drama
going on a lot of people
a lot of people are asking if you kick
the bucket
[Laughter]
i posted in the patreon i said hey you
know we got a family emergency on the
team blah blah blah because it's fully
okay
[Laughter]
sunglasses on just drops every couple of
seconds
no i don't want anybody to think because
people were saying in patreon because
they were worried you know what i mean
about you well no about hyena's split
real quick yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah nothing like that
just we're just we're just holding water
here until t-bone gets back
so we appreciate it we love you guys so
if any of the audio or video is [ __ ]
up
i don't know what i'm doing how about
how about that the kid came in he set
the whole thing
up so if this comes out and it looks and
sounds good give kippy a little shout
out and if it doesn't what i mean
blame foley that's what i do i did my
job i sat here and complained why he
said that's what i do when i [ __ ] up i
play foley anyway
uh but this is a family episode gang the
best of the best
the best of the best we love it we're
circling the wagons we're sitting down
we're gonna get some questions here
um i have a bit of business to start off
what do you got there big fellas i don't
even know how to approach it or if it's
uh
if it's podcast worthy but um two things
don't sell it too much i don't know if
this story is gonna suck or i don't
think it has legs but
you saw the tweet that i posted about my
mom's tv
in the thing yeah so you said that like
it made cnn
you saw the tweet that i posted right
what the [ __ ] you read the fat guy
tweets it's just
in did you read the times this morning
it's not good um
so i'm noticing some things here you
know what i mean by the way
i don't go check the tweet out it's
foley's mom
[ __ ] post she mounted her tv in the
corner of the bedroom like it's
like it's like she's working the
surveillance room at the bottom of the
wild wings
yeah only because my mom turned her
bedroom into a sports bar
which is a home run of a joke thank you
um
no that's trash we know the foleys are
you know we're a little garbagio
we'll say yeah um that's yeah sure but
i'm starting to see some things
that even stunned me so there was that i
see that i walk in the house i see that
and the second thing is um i was down
there for a couple of days
and we had a nice dinner on saturday we
made some salmon
salad all that kind of stuff and then
she said i just picture your family
catching them as they're jumping out of
the [ __ ]
jumping up the stream ah just biting
overall
the foleys are at it again you're in the
schuylkill me and my dad fighting over
one
um no so she goes at the end of the meal
now one thing i'll say about the foleys
is the cooking's on point the cooking's
on point
the coupling isn't too shabby either
guys come on this is what this is what
this is the bread and butter of the pod
the old
she does she'll throw a cutlet at you
that'll blow your [ __ ]
throw down um and for the rest she's
tiny she's a tiny bra
she is which is i mean she's like little
red riding hood she keeps it tight yeah
she keeps she's
she but compared to the rest of your
family you guys are big for the boys you
got a couple of big boys in that
my brother's pretty thin i'm just saying
but he's a bigger yeah he's a
not he's no he's a he's in good shape
but he's just a
bigger the foley's are a thick stock
thick stock
yeah and she's a tiny little she's tiny
yeah but she can throw it around
the marble keep the [ __ ] lbs on paddy
cranking the hundys out back
it's like a super slim fast just
crushing those things
paddy how do you do it
[Laughter]
just fill up more rounds um here's the
thing what shocked me
stunned me uh we're eating dinner
she's like oh my god i forgot the corn
she got corn on the cob
all right you know the produce down
there starting to pop springtime
[ __ ] northeast foleys like to get
their fresh produce in
yeah everybody knows the produce is
starting to pop that's how you really
keep up on the [ __ ] farmer's almanac
you know like a good tomato in the
spring i don't know what to tell you
yeah but you're like
the tweet and this you acted like front
page news you know the
produce is starting to pop anyway
she goes over to get the corn now the
corns usually in a huge pot boiling on
the stove
like a gentleman right yeah don't tell
me she microwaved it or something she
migrated
dude straight corn on the cob raw two of
them
in the microwave on the plate for like
15 minutes
yeah that's always been you got to do
that with a potato too
she walked over there and i saw michael
michael like what are you doing she's
like i'm getting the corner i'm like you
microwave the corn
is that that's unprecedented i wanted to
get your opinion on it
yeah i mean that's that's yeah i mean
i've made the
unfireable offense yeah that's not a
good look
she microwaved the corn and listen i was
hung i only ate half of it
oh wow it's good produce this time it's
crazy not microwaving i know
a microwave in anything that hasn't
already been like eating rubber bullets
[Laughter]
so i don't know what's going on down
there that's todd's wonky these bronzes
they get why i see it too they get a
little early
they get a little [ __ ] these girls
are bonkos down there
start doing goofy [ __ ] yeah i i i get
they cut the corner because then it's
these are tiny old broads right they
can't be lifting up a big pot of water
and boiling it
you don't know just throw it in a
microwave and look the other way i don't
care what happens to the world
could fall apart i need paddy foley on
point
all right i i need to eat i i can't be
getting shaking she's gotta be coming
with the high heat yeah she's already
she's starting to make frittatas for
breakfast which i'm [ __ ] a little bit
concerned about when she visits south of
the border i don't know
she's been cranking frittatas out at us
it's like yo bacon egg and cheese let's
[ __ ] keep the [ __ ] movie if it
ain't broke don't fix it yeah this is
america
let's go the same [ __ ] cancun were
you on spring break or something
let's [ __ ] go make with a bec
hey if i wanted to do a siesta i'll go
to madrid okay
do me a favor and get the scrapple
working will you
get the front get the griddle out and
let's be [ __ ] gentlemen
you shouldn't be here oh yeah it was
always where you do that in the oven
what the frittata if we finish she
finishes in the oven
yeah you want to know where i finish all
right
come on kid's weird i also finish in the
oven
it's weird all right guys uh this is a
family episode we're gonna be answering
your [ __ ] patreon question so as you
know when you join the pa i keep going
to [ __ ] camera one keep going there
t-bone we're just gonna look across
the cross-side the whole time an
invaluable part of the operation dude
anytime
since steven's come on and i've had to
edit something or do something i
literally sit there and i look at him
because it'll be like me smashing my
head against the computer for five hours
trying to line up my mouth with the
words or whatever and i literally look
at my wife i go t-bone is invaluable
you keep the plate spinning a little bit
though we'll get through this
yeah we'll get thro yeah because i mean
well i mean we're not relying on you by
the way i'm lucky you even showed up
got my phone camera
but guys as you know when you join uh
the patreon we will ask we will answer
your garbage question
uh it's just kind of the best way to do
it because we get so many requests and
stuff like that so when you join the
patreon we'll do it
and i gotta [ __ ] tell you tell me the
fans
are it's like jurassic park they're
learning right they're learning
the show they get they're figuring out
an open door this is the way they ever
get questions is [ __ ] home they're
funny
their whole their their [ __ ] home
runs the best squad i mean it really is
this one all right this i mean let's
just get into it and even
the way they emphasize the words in the
question
this is from trey ever drive yourself
somewhere in a karate uniform
if you're driving yourself to karate
that is a tough [ __ ] look dude
you don't change there they don't got
locker rooms i think he's saying you
shouldn't be an adult doing karate like
that's the way that like you're a kid
who's getting driven to
shouldn't be you shouldn't be of age of
driving age driving yourself to karate
in a karate game i'll say this if i did
do it i'd probably
like kramer if i did do it i'd probably
wear that thing all the time
yeah i don't think you're too far away
from wearing it it looks pretty comfy
yeah yeah it's like a robe with pants
right i would have one going the
opposite way i need you to go
i'm getting loose with my fashion just
getting more comfortable clothing
clothing made for people doesn't fit
anymore um that's a [ __ ] hole yeah
i was thinking this too like anything
you all you have a big beef with tiger
shoulders for some reason
also shulman's a jewish guy right what
do they know about the far east
and tiger in his first name i know that
somebody came to our high school
that's he adopted that that's that's
culture appropriation
no way a jewish family named their first
kid tiger he got that nickname at summer
camp somewhere
tiger shulman really was the only kid at
camp to not have an asthma attack
we're calling you tigers no he
definitely pushed
he definitely pushed the nate yo what's
up call me tiger
when he showed up to summer camp he said
well everybody at school calls me tiger
and then he came back to school because
everybody came calls me tiger
he really played both sides against the
middle that t shulman
just like a really bad thing ah my hand
um we had some [ __ ] jerk off [ __ ]
come and do a demonstration in high
school
he was like this dude i'll [ __ ] roll
on you dude he was like this
50 year old guy belly and he had some
lackey with him i don't care
why it was happening it was like english
class too and it was like junior year
just on a random wednesday
and there was no other presenters it's
all of a sudden there's this [ __ ] guy
wearing a [ __ ] karate suit
in front of the class so he's like i
need a volunteer so he like he was
[ __ ] this guy up for like 20 minutes
in class
ah like you know but the guy was it's a
goal [ __ ]
yeah the guy wasn't like fighting back
he was just letting him do the stuff
yeah that's how he always do it yeah
it's like you come over here i'll
[ __ ] give you a stone cold stunner
so he brings me up and this is the movie
you're getting a three-point stance boom
hot round hot rock you want to dance old
man
do you dive across the desk you [ __ ]
spear them
he made me get into the position he like
put me in a headlock
and he's like now i'm gonna show you a
move and it's moving let's just finger
up
[Laughter]
no this was the move he pinched me
my head hurts wait what he pinched me he
goes down and pinches
or no i put him in a headlock and to get
out he pinched you
he pinches my inner thigh like what kind
of kinky [ __ ]
dude i had a bruise let's keep it above
board here all right dude
we're playing gentlemen's rules
no biting noah no fish hooks that's
another real trashy thing a fish hog
i thought we said no nutsies oh god
dude dude fish hooks my my cousin my
cousin liam there should be a coat of
got me with a fish hook one time when we
were kids he plays dirt they're all
[ __ ] kenzos
dude they're real dirt that's my biggest
feat oh he got fishhawk and remember we
called him an irish toothache
back here you would like there's the
pressure point behind your ear
dude you get some kills but somebody
presses that you see
stars baby you [ __ ] you're down for
the count
what the photo [ __ ] mortal kombat
what the [ __ ] are you guys doing man
it's thanksgiving have a drink and relax
this is a single valley household and
this piece was working third shift right
we were it was lawless
yeah [ __ ] tiger shulman's
oh that was and he dude they got to have
a locker room there
i get the question i understand but i'm
just saying yeah there's no
there's no reason if you if you're into
karate and you're an adult
there's no reason you should be wearing
that [ __ ] on the way you're stopping at
a coffee when you're in there
hey what the [ __ ] that's the guy who
really wants to show you he's into
karate
yeah if i walked into a dunkin donuts
and there was a guy sitting there in a
karate uniform in line
i'd [ __ ] walk the right hand [ __ ]
trip
yeah i mean that's the same thing they
can cheese in half
yeah that'd be like if you play football
and you show that you're standing in
line at starbucks
in a [ __ ] helmet and shoulder pads
and cleats
like buddy we get it you show up to
school full uniform
in the morning oh fantastic fantastic
question
uh the next one too this is from tyler p
have you ever intentionally been one of
the first
5 000 at a stadium for the free merch
giveaway
like to get the bobble head i think i
have been
inadvertently i know i've gotten a mini
bat before
yeah but that was like trent like those
are you know they give them to everybody
when you walk in
oh yeah that's the incentive the dollar
dog night count because i've been
[ __ ] first in line
5 000 dogs oh man um no but like to go
get the bobble head or whatever we never
[ __ ] with that no
that was always like that's fine my dad
would always be like yeah you key i
don't i don't want to be carrying it
we got their second inning [ __ ] walk
down to the [ __ ] or walked up to the
seats or whatever
knows me to walk yeah you're not walking
down anywhere no [ __ ] huge
tray of [ __ ] nachos hot dogs drinks
[ __ ] slurp them down for a couple
innings and then get the [ __ ] out of
there
well yeah that's a tough luck if you're
waiting in line at a [ __ ] stadium
in a karate uniform uh
this is from wesley shout out to wesley
uh
have you ever owned an exercise bike
that wasn't one of those pelotons
which i feel is a direct shot at me
because i have you were just making fun
of me yesterday
i have the cheapo deep i got the cheapo
i got one that does laundry
[Laughter]
that's how my internet works it's like
[ __ ] gilligan's island i got ginger
working the [ __ ] ones and two
uh yeah i have like i bought like a
cheap one during quarantine
uh no is there buttons on it yeah
like it's not it's not that does it have
a screen belt does it have a computer
screen yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's not that's not yeah
it's not too shabby but
it seems it's a schwinn schwinn yeah so
it's just a bike
no schwinn makes [ __ ] they do i think
so yeah you couldn't ride it on the
street if you wanted to
no there's no wheels there's no wheels
at all
i don't know because if you got one that
has the back wheel you're [ __ ] trash
i don't think zero no there's no wheels
all right there's no wheels it's just
like a [ __ ]
yeah it's small it was like 180 bucks or
something like that it seems
to be the name of the game these days
the peloton
that's class yeah you gotta get a pellet
time i brought i got fam my brother's
got one those things are like a [ __ ]
jihad out the gate yeah they are they
also have that big ass track or that big
uh
what's it called uh stair treadmill
they got that big ass treadmill now too
i don't even know what you're talking
about
yeah they got something it's nuts so you
don't have it
[Laughter]
you should get one we to get you in
shape a little
bit i can walk outside but you don't but
i wouldn't walk inside either
well maybe you would we have a treadmill
i can't use it though
why 220 weight limit you can't
you'll never be able to use it no it
can't be
220 that means i couldn't it's a little
guy yeah it's a little one
wait back this up this you have
a [ __ ] [ __ ] my girl ordered it for
her she uses it
how how big is it it's tiny what's just
give me dimensions here
i mean i'm not sleeping on it if that's
any indication
i tried wait two
that's gotta be tiny it's tiny the
average american is
uh averaging american male is like 200
it's an epidemic it's tough how much was
it
not much a couple hundred bucks 60 bucks
i was thinking about getting a peloton
making the whole room a workout room
sauna everything
whirlpool ice bath tiger shulman
tiger falls they're franchising it's
great
[ __ ] these allergies man oh party
i've been jacked up and
jacked up here dude gang spring is here
and that means summer's right around the
corner and you want to get out there and
you want to be adventurous and you got
to get
bespoke post for all your adventures
with a new line of essentials in their
box of
awesome all right it's the box of
awesome collection and it's absolutely
fantastic
and it's guaranteed to upgrade your life
whether you're out there tame in the
wilderness
or whether you're taking your home bar
to a pro level
bespoke post is the only company you
want to be working with
their box of awesome is absolutely
fantastic and has you covered
from style and grooming goods to
borrower to cooking utensils
or even outdoor gear the box of awesome
has collections for every part of your
life
yeah guys uh they sent us a bunch of
cool [ __ ]
um they sent us some they sent me a new
duffel bag got a hammock got a hammock
got this cool blanket
uh i can't wait i needed a new duffel
bag anyway this one's [ __ ] dope i
feel like
it's like uh it's high quality it's got
like a metal ring at the top i can't
wait to take it on the road to the next
show
it's [ __ ] cool it's cool it's cool
guys stuff it's cool guy [ __ ] yeah and
that you don't know where to get it
really they [ __ ] got all this cool
[ __ ] so
to get started take the quiz at box of
awesome.com your answers will help them
pick the right box of awesome for you
they release new boxes every month
across a ton of different categories
travel home bar whatever you're into
they got
it's free to sign up and you can skip a
month or cancel at any time
each box is only 45 bucks but it has
over 70 dollars worth of gear in it
you'll be losing money not to do this
what are we talking about get on this
uh so get 20 off your first monthly box
when you sign up at box of all
box of awesome dot com and enter the
code garbage baby you know the code it's
always garbage
enter the code garbage at checkout
that's box of awesome.com promo code
garbage for 20
off your first box folks this podcast is
brought to you by
better help okay is there something in
your life interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals
then get on better help better help will
assess your needs
and match you with their own licensed
professional
therapist yeah they're not just dishing
out pills all right
they're taking the extra step you can
start communicating within 48 hours
it's not a crisis line it's not a
self-help line
it's professional counseling done
securely
online yeah guys uh therapy for me was a
game changer
as you know me and foley are both kind
of mental emotional messes
and when i started going to therapy a
few years ago it was a game changer
really you find out what what's going on
they have answers
for you you find out you're not the only
schmuck dealing with these things you
know what i mean
everybody's got something going on and
betterhelp wants you to start living a
happier life today so visit their
website and read the testimonials
that are posted daily by all the people
it's betterhelp.com
reviews you can find out from real
people who it helps uh
it's available in all 50 states our
special offer for ru garbage listeners
you get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
garbage one more time guys special offer
for
our listeners if you're thinking about
starting therapy if you're kicking the
tires
if you need a little help this is the
place to do it go to betterhelp.com
garbage gang real quick i want to talk
to you about hello
fresh what is it mm-hmm a little bit of
cash the big leagues baby the big
leagues these are big players hello
fresh
big sponsors big company fantastic
company
but what is hellofresh so hellofresh you
get
fresh pre-measured ingredients
mouth-watering seasonal recipes
delivered right to your door skip the
trips to the grocery store
and count on hellofresh to make home
cooking
easy fun and affordable and that's why
it's america's number one meal kit
hellofresh cuts out to stressful meal
planning and meal prepping
you know what i mean yeah they they make
it easy for you yeah they got meals at
already in 20 minutes or less lightening
prep recipes quick breakfast lunches
snacks whatever it is they sent us two
boxes
and i gotta tell you it's dude first of
all if you're going to the grocery store
and buying
the recipes it's going to cost ten
thousand dollars i don't know if you try
to go shopping and buy
all the [ __ ] you need like who has raw
mustard seeds or whatever
they they send you everything you need
me and my wife
do it it's a good night in the kitchen
you're not fighting you don't have to
figure it out it's easy peasy yeah
you're not arguing at the grocery store
over what you know
what preserved lemons look like or
whatever it's easy
what are you doing um so go to
hellofresh.com
garbage12 and use code garbage12
you know why it's garbage 12 because you
get 12 free meals
including free shipping go to
hellofresh.com
garbage12 use promo code garbage 12 and
get 12 free meals
plus free shipping guys it's easy peasy
um it's highly encouraged uh
i highly encourage you to do it uh it's
america's number one
he's got 12 free meals i'm all hopped up
on free meals baby
uh it's america's number one meal kit
one more time hellofresh.com
garbage12 use promo code garbage12 get
your 12 free meals now back
to the show um all right next one
coming in let's see let's get uh this
is from michael
uh ever gave the family computer a virus
from downloading porn
i didn't but a family member did patty
no this was early this was
listen well i mean we've already named
all of the family members in your
i didn't say it was an immediate family
member risque
it was a it was uh one of the patriarchs
possibly
okay bottom line is most dads in the
early 2000s
we're snooping ruined a computer and
would take it to the grave
as to why oh of course oh to the great
yeah and probably not even looking at
anything that bad
yeah it's just remember back then it was
[ __ ]
they they were coming through the
computer actually i know it was the
while as soon as you made a wrong move
yeah that was before pop-up blockers oh
man everything would just start playing
oh you're like oh [ __ ] you got
everything i'll plug the speakers
ready to go [ __ ] candles are lit oh
you have the garage door open you gotta
[ __ ]
[ __ ] blow out the candles put your
pants back on close the laptop slide it
under the computer
just slide another desk um i got caught
one time not
caught but i you know that was the
specific reason i got
the iphone that there was no way that i
was gonna
get an android why because they because
they said that
iphones couldn't get viruses and
androids can
i think so i don't think that was the
sales that that's what i thought it was
told yesterday
jobs but that was the selling point for
me
i don't know i knew i was gonna really
get viruses like that i knew i would be
perusing certain video solutions
but i think if you stay on like the
pornhubs oh nowadays
yeah whatever professional it's like
going to google yeah um
but mainstream there was a desktop in
the basement where
you know from time to time i would uh i
would indulge in you know
the it was the family computer the sins
of the flesh
i would dance with the devil somebody
hold my peanut butter roll it's naughty
time
go right back up grab something to eat
um
not even miss a beat on the couch so i
think if i don't know i was older
like maybe i don't want to say high
school i don't know old like high school
it was like
you know whatever and nobody really used
the compute my parents didn't use the
computer for anything like you know they
weren't there was no like online banking
and like the emails and [ __ ] they
weren't communicating via
um so you know i would get a little
loose with the downloads sometimes
whatever and i got kind of hemmed up
i'm 10 years older than you but so you
were
in your adolescence we were talking
limewire
or was there no this was like webs with
the big one was free ones was the
website free ones
and it was shout out to free ones it was
just like it was just like a like a
pornhub like you could watch videos for
free
yeah and you but it was all like it was
i think that was like the first time
that they were like all centered in a
place where it was like every
yeah because i remember you'd search by
name but then like you would just stream
you didn't have to download anything you
would just stream you would just play
the video right like there was no
download and you go like who are you
[ __ ] up a laptop with limewire so my
you know i had done this and maybe you
know
left some cookies or whatever you know
it was like [ __ ] it got him they got
jammed up a bit it was a little slow
got clogged up i clogged the pipes
cookies will get you off this thing
and uh yeah so my mom
what a nice turn for a little bastard
yeah i really get you
um it should be called demon hawks or
something like that demon coins
um i go away for the week the week and
the something i don't i while i'm gone
because i used to run
security on the computer a little bit
you know what i mean if my mom's like
this something's acting up i'm like i'll
take a look at it don't be calling no
third parties in here okay i don't need
anybody snooping
around my files
so i got important tax tax documents
i got confidential [ __ ] on here
what are we doing you can look at it but
you got to sign an
so she she calls my brother-in-law who's
kind of a techie guy
right like he knows computer like you
know better than more
how old are you i'm a teenager where
it's like knowing that i'm [ __ ]
you know i'm weasel it off from time to
time it's it's not like
it's not shocking you know what i mean
i'm a grown man still
so he
i don't know i come back and it's just
kind of like a thing where i think it's
all
settled like my mom's like there was an
issue with the computer we had to reboot
the main frame and i'm like well i'm
sure i
got caught like let's not talk let's be
[ __ ]
let's be gentlemen here and except that
i got caught and let's move
forward without acknowledging said issue
just past the green beans please
i'll take my coffee in my room so
we're like at dinner at my mom's house
and like you know we have that big
counter and like we're like it's like
appetizers
that night no like a week or something
who's doing apps
what was it a party no like when like my
bro like everybody was out of the house
like my sister but they were coming over
for like sunday dinner or whatever and
they would just be like you know
bread and [ __ ] oh dipping oils and
some shrimp or whatever on the [ __ ]
not bad and i spread it yeah they do it
all right so
uh my brother he was like dipping
something and he's like yeah kevin
[ __ ] something something watching the
dirty videos on the computer i'm like yo
what the [ __ ] dude
i'm like i got the [ __ ] the great
kids are wrong what are you doing you
got crab cakes here what are you doing
calling me out in front of i wasn't that
was a [ __ ] tackle
i'm like dude what the [ __ ] yeah man
we all know what we were doing it was
the 90s
don't let kevin put his hands in the dip
man
[ __ ] really calling me out so they
were able to
pinpoint that see well i think they i
mean like my mom was only going to aol
to check her mail
and like you know tdbank.net
all the other websites were like
facebook [ __ ]
you know xxn.x yeah there was never any
convictions in in
our family there was there was the
burden of proof was too high yeah there
was there was suspect
yeah but i i got hemmed up back i got
this individual he
stayed strong kept his mouth shut yeah
take that to the grave oh
yeah yeah i have no idea i don't know
you know i don't know
not saying who it was i don't know who
jenna jameson is get [ __ ] out of here
never even met that broad that's trash
um all right this is from max first time
asker uh lazy susan as a centerpiece of
the dining room table
and then also compared to the cupboard
the cupboard's trash no the cupboard's
trash
no there's dude that's mouse city back
there
they were great when you were a kid
remember when you were a kid i used to
get in there and spin around
yeah take it for a take before it was
like a merry-go-round dude that might
have all been the rosetta stone when i
was a kid that thing
fascinated me yeah i thought there was
like a whole village or something back
there
yeah it's also scary too um yeah yeah
you really had to have the perfect
amount of stuff in it if you had
too little it looked real creepy when
you spun that around
sure you know the [ __ ] garlic salts
rolling around wait well where
was yours yours was up here we didn't
have a [ __ ] lazy
susan countertop what
we don't have one now you don't have
lazy susan cash
that no that was rich people should she
had one that was we just got the [ __ ]
kitchen redone
let's take the [ __ ] lazy sues for a
spin let's take her out
it's a sunday let's let her hair down no
my cousins had that we didn't have that
she had one we had the down the bottom
one it's
yeah under yeah some people have them in
the corner yeah but some people have
them up here that's trash
we didn't keep food in ours though no
you kept salt and you kept no we didn't
even keep that we kept like
uh tupperware the strainers that kind of
stuff so there was no
yeah okay and that was good we got a big
mama jam it should be for seasonings is
what it should this one i mean no like
this one's like this but you couldn't
you'd have to have ten thousand things
of seasoning this was more of like a
utility one rather than like uh
how big was it i just told you it was
like that [ __ ] but it stopped at the
countertop it wasn't like
it wasn't like a [ __ ] money grab
booth was it
i'll never forget when my mom did that i
was like you [ __ ]
this is the most i was sitting there at
like some [ __ ] sebring dealership me
and my brother with my head in my hand
being like this is embarrassing she got
in there huh
yeah just like licking her arm and stuff
no i'm kidding i'm kidding
i'm kidding who talked her into it the
sales guy i think
i forget it was hairy i just remember
being really embarrassed
um what you walk away with i don't even
know i can't really remember if she even
got in i'm drawing a blank but
it was uh it was a tough it was a tough
it was a it was touch and go
for a minute poor broad's trying to get
her to get a couple of bucks don't
afford the car
i would have freaked out meanwhile i
think we got away i would have leaked
it was like [ __ ] 96 and we were
buying like an 88 taurus or something
we were like trying to save nine bucks
on it some salesman had a bulls eye on
her
i'll tell you that take this bro down
for a drink
chop these two i just saw older pics of
her she was a good looking gal
the piece the piece good looking gown
now all right tough guy
let me get my karate game if i can start
pinching the inside of your gooch
um lazy susan on the table love it
we have one all the time it's old school
it's marble
from is it built into the table or is it
a third party
establishment well it's not a [ __ ]
korean barbecue restaurant what the [ __ ]
is
it
got a hot pot you walk in get in there
with a shrimp
paco oh man you stink
it's built into the table well i think
some of them like on these old school
tables they would have it like
i feel it would be built in no you idiot
it just fits we were not a lazy susan
that's to me is trash you on the table
you put it you put the
you put you know the mashed potatoes the
peas of this and that and you spin it
around
you don't got to reach over it's nice
everything about your family is just
making it easier more convenient to eat
the mic microwave in corn [ __ ] lazy
susan so you get your hands on potatoes
quicker i'm putting the cake
easy on the starches folies all right
i'm putting the kybash on that [ __ ]
corn thing
that's [ __ ] nuts um fool me once
patty pull me once
all right this is from mark uh new
patreon member uh
ever been the guy who wiped a booger on
the wall while standing at the urinal
oh yeah why do you get the need to pick
your nose at a urinal
because you're freshening up you want to
clear out yeah got it you know what i
started doing in the morning is i just i
don't
i really don't want to know i just blow
into the sink to clean everything out
your nose yeah and then i clean the sink
out dude i would never i'm never gonna
go to your apartment
ever hey listen whacker all right whack
you're over there pulling it shaking
your hand
um no
yeah i would do it i would do i would
pick and then flick i wouldn't wipe
because i wouldn't want to touch the
wall because i know other boogers were
there
are there other dudes standing next to
you at the urinal no i'm not a [ __ ]
animal
you know where i get you you know where
i would go to my old job when i worked
in center city
you know where i'm suspect is in the car
you get me in the car alone
don't check the bottom of the brand new
kia dude that's like a [ __ ]
stalactites down there oh good they're a
clean house on the turnpike no one's
gonna know
my time fingers got fingers in the easy
pass lane it was always uh a shocking
thing when you saw when you saw like a
dried booger
on like the bus yeah it's like on the
back seat
i mean wet is worse yeah wets i don't
know why you would wipe it on the wall
that's weird that's almost like
nowhere else to put it you roll it up
and flick it
i don't know just something i would go
like
you're only looking at a wall the urinal
is this animal
i don't know but i like them um
i did that one did that one um
i mean this if you're doing this you're
in bed this is from adam did your
parents ever have roommates
that weren't relatives yeah we talked
about that did we
that's a tough that was the question do
you ever ever did your family family
ever have roommates
god love you that's it man talk about
being hemmed up that's the definition of
him
put a pause in the sleepovers for a
while
troy's staying with us some drifter my
one buddy had that
they didn't need to do it they had they
had a big house
but there was this dude that lived like
in the attic
all through high school i knew you'd see
him like once every three months
and the entrance was through the house
he would like just walk into the house
and go upstairs and
there was like an apartment up there it
blew my
[ __ ] mind how much money could you be
making in a
probably a couple hundo you probably
need that's a you know maybe it comes a
handful of g
odds a year maybe a couple hundred i
never understood it
oh they're daughters too
hot ones oh oh yeah there's no way i had
dog that's like
textbook that's like the green mile
that's how it's out starts
what well that's how the same sam
rockwell was was
working for the guy on the farm with the
two daughters yeah
i can explain the plot of green mile to
you let's go i
just thought it was about eating bees
again
fantastic movie um that's a tough look
man that's a hard look
another family or something like that
maybe
but if it's like one dude one dude it's
like a weird
no uh what are you doing where are you
going
how long are you staying in town why
don't you get yeah you have references
yeah i don't know what's happening and
what why do you want to live with a
family
exactly what's going on with this guy
exactly that's why let's ask him some
questions
exactly not happy days i'll give you
because the fonz lived out back
you got to guess that that was big on
that was big on
sitcoms and then especially in the 90s
it was
there was always the bozo in the back
cory was that his name
on what was family member who was the
guy who ended up beating his wife he
lived in the van
cody right i don't know what you're
talking about
what that seems like a dark time for a
family matter step by step
thanks to our on the show he hit his
wife no that'd be a dark episode
trying to loosen it up on a friday night
yeah
jesus christ remember that episode where
urkel was addicted to opiates guys
wilson's beating the [ __ ] out of his
hook get over here you just hear like
the
plates smashing against the walls and
[ __ ] that's tough
uh yeah no good garbagio yeah
all right the the two of these we've
touched on before this is from tony two
splints
[Laughter]
yeah tony tony two splints um long time
trash bag first time question asker ever
lied about
someone dying to get out of going to
work yeah we've you did that
masterfully where you like you made five
different calls some were fake
acted like you were calling your boss
calling your dad yeah
yeah yeah yeah sure i don't know if i've
ever gone that far
because of the catholic guilt a little
bit but i've definitely
you know i've i've said family emergency
a bunch
always keep it vague family because dude
in college they can't double they can't
come back on a family emergency you know
i would i would be too superstitious to
say like
so and so died unless they're unless
they've already passed
yeah then you're playing with house
money yeah you know what i mean yeah
yeah i always thought uh funerals and
stuff like that
can be checked out you always go sick
i'm sick
yeah do something to throw them off to
make them
think that you're not lying yeah which
was my move when i
called my boss and told him that i
couldn't make anything because i was
really sick then i called him back
pretending that i thought it was my dad
yeah like dad i'm real sick man you
gotta help me
he's like oh it's me you're okay go to
bed you're having fever dreams
sucker uh so meanwhile you're forgot a
mai tai in your hand
um yeah i would always say i'm on my way
in
and i i always thought
i would lie about the time i would wait
until like
20 minutes till i was kind of supposed
to be there class started or whatever
and be like hey i'm on my way in
i just don't have it in like i always
felt that was more believable
oh like a few hours out like hey i'm not
feeling not even making the effort
yeah listen i woke up notice i was
trying to muscle through it i just don't
have i really don't have it in me
i don't want to get anybody else sick
yeah it's like oh yeah i don't want to
be busy on the train yeah i don't want
to make it worse and then be out for
more days i'm really sorry
you know uh one time i was uh my my
cousin was in town
you know nowadays
i find that like people that have like
real jobs don't need to do that
they just take literally it's an email
hey listen i'm not feeling well i'm not
coming in today or hey i'm taking a
personal day
yeah what do you think it is without
having to explain anything
yeah dude see i think that's my i always
think someone is watching me and i have
to explain myself
i always feel like you're crazy
you are an absolute insane person but i
never had a job where i could do that i
i always had you always worked you
always waited tables you can't send an
email to [ __ ] john applebee's or
whatever where i was like the only
waiter working like that lunch shift and
i was all banged up the night before
just couldn't do it couldn't do it um
i one night i remember so much guilt and
pressure and like what the [ __ ]
yeah when you're working at a bigger
company there's less like i was there's
[ __ ] nine other bozos doing the same
job or whatever you know
um some of my boys that have real jobs
like i just took a personal date just to
dis i'm like what
you're not sweating it you're not
worried you're gonna get fired
next time we're supposed to record i'm
going to get a text listen
i can't make it i'm taking kippy i'm
taking a personal deck
buddy as for hr you have
no personal days no okay no sick time
no paid off no vacation what about
maternity leave
because you look like you're about to
pop
twins coming uh yeah you get no personal
days
universal pre-k pre-k yeah prenatal
no pre-k universal pre-k as in
uh nursing school or i'm sorry school
nursery school
is that what it's called nursery school
it's a kindergarten no it's kebab
what do you asking i don't know what
you're asking me are you asking me if we
provide that
hoodie inc yes if we provide
preschool for your kids that you don't
have yes
in the future if i wanted to start a
family yeah you could bring they can sit
on the couch and toby can watch we
record
i'm sure t-bone's great with kids oh man
that good uh all right um
i remember one time i was working my
cousin came up he was like i'm in new
york
it was like nine o'clock i'm like oh
it's me for a drink
and we don't we don't have governors on
us nine o'clock turned into
[ __ ] 4 a.m closing down some [ __ ]
irish pub in midtown
and just like dude i got to get up for
work this is when i was working at the
law firm outside in
new rochelle so i have to take oh you
want to just tell you something gang
this kid had a tough ride by air by land
by sea i would get you
i used to have to take the subway to
a bus take the bus across town to the
bronx and then get on the metro north
and take the metro north
to new rochelle and then walk like 10
minutes bro you're taking the bus to
work
it's tough i would take every full
everything i took everything but a ferry
that new york city had to offer
step in front of it next time oh man
that's a tough look i was like do i have
to be up at like six especially in a
small market you're not even in new york
i know
in the hustle and bustle i know you used
to you're going a new rochelle
i was [ __ ] dude i was thinking i was
making like 12 bucks an hour or
something
who lives in manhattan and works me i
was trying to do it i was trying
to work i was in a bad place trying to
make it right okay i was in a bad place
with even worse people
but i remember my friend she worked hr
for it was a huge company oh yeah she
worked hr you used to get to play the
fiddle a little bit a little bit but
there's somebody on the inside i had
someone playing the ones and two did she
not eventually turn on you and
and and sandbagging or am i missing
you're miss
you're misremembering um uh but you i
thought there was one time where she was
like
here's 2 500 bucks now i have to turn my
back on you
what for something i thought you liked
you were trying to get her to play ball
and she wouldn't play ball on one thing
i don't think so no no no no no maybe
i'm getting confused with good fellas
yeah i got caught selling dope in
pittsburgh
i thought i told you no dope treat me
like a jerk um
[Music]
but i sent the email because i'm like
there's no way i'm gonna wake up
at it's not four i'm not gonna be home
until five
i'm like there's no way i'm gonna wake
or whatever i'm like i'm no way i'm
gonna wake up at seven and be like hey i
can't make it in
okay so i sent the email at like four
a.m so you're just probably spelling
errors whether it's a yes or no you're
live i'm just saying hey i'm taking a
sick day
okay i'm taking a sick day okay but that
comes in at 4 00 a.m
two minutes after last call you look
like a [ __ ] jerk
no you woke up in the middle of the
night with a fever sure that's what it
was and
that's what i was trying to say but she
then sent me the emails that they were
like they got it and they were because i
had to send it to my first boss and like
cchr or whatever
and like that went up to corporate
change so she sees it all and she sent
it to me she's like
they all just know you were out drinking
till 4am like
100 and they were like the one thing was
like does anybody believe
kevin whatever dude let's [ __ ] party
yeah dude the booze gets me man i like
the sauce it's in my bones you like the
sauce you think we'd learn by now though
i i went out last night with a buddy
from home it was oddly enough sitting
two feet away that we're ignoring
shout out to flippa and we just the boo
like joe i
just can't stop boozing and i wake up i
feel like [ __ ] today
i can't do that anymore it's like the
thing you said like sleeping on the
couch and stuff like that
i can't do it i can't do it anymore it's
tough i needed a complete day off
yeah it needs to be i'm hurting i'm
dragging there needs to be tylenol pms
there needs to be some eddies some great
some gatorade too will [ __ ]
gotta be gatorade he can't get up and
[ __ ] push it at 7 30 anymore
brutal brutal all right you want to kill
yourself
um this is from arion haven't heard it
asked yet do you have a favorite glass
or cup to drink out of
i for sure at my mom's house i and even
now oh yeah but at your mom's house you
have one that's like 25 years old oh
i got a [ __ ] i have a notre dame pint
glass but it's a guinness glass
stack that thing without a handle or no
like that kind of pine glass or like a
like a like a no it's not a flue hammer
it's a [ __ ] pink
handle oh yeah some pine glasses have
[ __ ] handles oh like a mug yeah
well i mean you act like that's crazy
exactly i asked if it had a [ __ ] face
like a head on it i'm not in cheers
[Laughter]
everybody knows you're fat
glass like the yeah with a little
the little [ __ ] crush that with ice
dude mine was good
mine was a [ __ ] growing up and i like
i don't know i doubt
i have grown up it was something plastic
dude ours was from a flyers playoff game
in like 92 or whatever
just always smelled like hawaiian
punches man of the [ __ ]
paint was and this thing was it must
have been 78 ounces like this thing
was huge oh you got it it was always on
the top shelf
like it was like it didn't fit on the
regular shelves it had to go on the
[ __ ]
yeah she didn't want your fat ass
[ __ ] drinking 72 ounces of soda
of coke for breakfast yeah um
that's fantastic which i do i don't mind
a coke zero with breakfast well i'm not
gonna poke zero
let me tell you something i'm off diet
coke i don't know what a diet coke with
an omelette
is really nice with a little lemon big
fan
big fan it's trashy and it's psychopath
[ __ ] to sit there and have
[ __ ] scramby eggs and a coke zero you
look
like a lunatic i don't know anybody that
drinks diet coke religiously that isn't
a psycho
like it's just a shot at me no well it's
i'm off the diet cokes by the way that's
good yeah but it's still in you you're
that kind of guy
oh i'm a dc guy yeah yeah so and you're
a psycho
i mean you have for sure dude yeah like
tom cruise harvey weinstein like those
are like
diet coke guys why do you limp if i can
lump me in with harvey weinstein dude
who does that you're the king of that
[ __ ]
[ __ ] slowly sh i blatantly [ __ ] on
you
but you really [ __ ] you play the i
think i said yeah i played the long game
i think i dropped a little a lot of
[ __ ] easter eggs for people to pick
up on
and then all of a sudden they're like oh
kippy harvey wines they start putting
dude
next time they hear diet coke they're
going to think of me and a rapist the
btk killer
no i think i was thinking of tom cruise
portraying somebody similar to harvey
weinstein and tropic thunder
who drank a lot of diamonds
all right this one's a little bit uh all
right let's see here um
this is from johnny uh have you have you
and your significant other
ever ordered a double drink at the bar
and split it
i don't even like splitting [ __ ]
appetizers i definitely ain't splitting
a [ __ ] rum and coke
you and your significant other go to the
bar it's because
ordering a dog this is my my take on it
ordering a of double rum and coke is
probably cheaper than two single rum and
cokes by how much
i mean i'm sure it's i'm sure johnny has
done the math
and it's probably by two bucks maybe i
don't know anybody that does that
[ __ ]
at a restaurant it drives me [ __ ]
crazy
i sneak in a flask at that point like if
you're gonna be a dirt ball
do it right yeah no that's that's no
good yeah
sitting there splitting a double come on
man ask for two straws can we get a
double rum and coke and an empty glass
with ice for her please
that's a [ __ ] tough look
people do it now if you're just banging
something down on your way out of the
restaurant
after dinner hey let me get a double you
take a big pull she takes a big pull
that's trashy though too
on your way out that's like if you had a
double and you're like hey i can't
finish this and you both are like
yeah yeah sit and enjoy it like a
[ __ ] gentleman don't be you can't be
an adult like kind of half standing up
slugging your [ __ ] drink
on your way out the door why not i do
that all the time because my girlfriend
usually never finishes her drink or her
beer
so i [ __ ] knocked that back on the
way out always
yeah so i'm saying that's different not
leaving cards in the table yeah no
[ __ ] way [ __ ] animal
um go this is from elle peters
first timer even the way he says it yo
anyone grow up with one pair of scissors
whole family would share them for any
task from prepping dinner school
assignments to cutting dog's asshair
yeah man we had one set
yeah and then they were orange handled
like most
most of america i'm sure ours were
lethal yeah ours would slice you
bad slicia they were no joke they were
not a toy
yeah um we
we never used i never even heard of
using scissors for cooking
until like i started working in a
restaurant yeah yeah i never [ __ ] cut
anything let's use the [ __ ] knife
yeah but yeah of course but like you
would use it for like
some to like maybe open a food poucher
at the same time what was always
i mean scissors cutting off the top of
an ice pop that was
[ __ ]
baby i'd have like two of them oh yeah
good
night like a [ __ ] gentleman raise him
up like a
there's a [ __ ] flute start coming up
charming snake oh this is all the
[ __ ] snakes in the neighborhood come
to your house yeah
that was the village flute like
rumpelstiltskin
who played the flute um
[Laughter]
that was after three years of [ __ ]
chewing it off like an
animal and it never was a good fight it
was never and it would cut your [ __ ]
it would get you here yeah yeah well
[ __ ] you look like the joker here's
my here's my question
i thought that was gonna kill come on i
was thinking i was thinking about the
next play
um do you take the do you always eat the
little nugget
buddy how long have you known me jerk
off how long have you been how long
i'd rather i'd rather they should just
make those i would cut it and you have
to have a bigger top oh yeah
i mean i take a couple inches off the
top those do need a couple of minutes
though you get a freeze pop
you got it you got you gotta fall you
gotta you gotta yeah ten minutes yeah
not ten
i mean ten minutes you let it sit for 10
minutes
it's not a red wine what are we doing
let's go [ __ ]
couple of seconds in the hand the second
one was always better because
it it that's what i'm saying like a
steak
let it sit it still cooks oh man
um ice pops this summer it's almost
about that time
i was talking to my boy about that yeah
club foley's going to be opening up soon
end of this month maybe we throw a big
patreon party there i'd love it
also by the way that i was there was uh
i we should do it
either on the patreon or at something
there's that
we had talked about it at some point
before there's that mcdonald's in the
old mansion
on long island do you ever see that no
here i pull it up there's a mcdonald's
on long island
okay that is in a huge old mansion
okay and it look and it's like fancy i
don't we we gotta go to it okay
uh is there table service i don't know
but you gotta hear look at this thing
now you have to you're gonna have to do
a graphic now no i'm not yeah
you guys can google it mo first of all
most of the people are listening to this
you're pinning us into that thing right
that is
let's see right it's in a [ __ ] proper
huge mansion
let's go you open the house you also owe
me a limo ride
oh shout out we just hit yo [ __ ] i
forgot uh we just hit 1300 and that was
foley's first limo ride you
never [ __ ] go guys never been in a
limo not for
pride i want a full not a funeral i want
suits
i want to we're doing somewhere maybe a
couple of hookers if our wives are out
of town
i think it would be so funny if we got a
couple of old [ __ ] hookers
let's do it and not have sex with them
no maybe a little cut little hand stuff
no i'm kidding um dinner we need some
arm candy
escorts right like gentlemen we need we
need some [ __ ] arm candy
maybe we go out to this mcdonald's
we got the limo for the day go out to
long island
that's it a nice meal oh dude
couple of bronzers couple of ladies of
the night yeah
you'll get the broads we're gonna get
you a suit that fits yeah
me and t-bone we're gonna come pick you
up in a limo yeah we're gonna head out
to [ __ ] long island it'll be
photography
yeah t-bone's gonna be doing it all when
i come down yeah t-bone's gonna
yeah yeah okay maybe a red carpet i'll
get a corsage
um well you have a suit though you have
a size are you gonna break my balls
about mcdonald's no i think i'll allow
uh one meal no extra burgers
what wait i don't even know what that
means dude what do you mean
no extra burgers yeah you always get
like a burger or two
with the meat no we i don't so you
everybody does that what
to go what do you mean if i if i go to
mcdonald's and i get a number three
i'm getting a mcdouble and a mcchicken
on the side too
right no dude right am i crazy
that's nuts but holy [ __ ] that's the
plan okay
we'll hit a drive through two in the
limo gotta do that maybe you know
after we have our nice meal at
mcdonald's he'll wait outside we'll get
him a burger
oh is there a drive-through with this
thing i don't know i'm not driving
through
we're dining in
[Laughter]
table for three please table for four oh
yeah you're abroad
you gotta have your lady of the night go
down to the docks pick up some real
skeezers yeah
um yeah that's it so that's what we'll
do so we just hit 1300 on patreon the
goal was for
foley's first uh
first limo ride yeah i want a proper
limo i don't want a [ __ ] hummer
i'll be the i get to choose i want
something
something i listen all right these are
the ones i'm picking either something
really [ __ ] gaudy and flashy
like a yellow hummer or something i
don't like to dance [ __ ]
what do you mean like where they have
like a pole and like the lights are
going off in there
i like an old-school limo how do you
know you've never been in any of them
i know what a [ __ ] old little this is
this is the crux of art this is the crux
of ours i want the limousine from
crocodile dundee
that's if i can get you an old one with
a boomerang that's for sure what i'm
getting
i feel like i hope this driver plays
ball if you know what i mean
a couple of nosebears on the road
he better be [ __ ] i want him dressed
up if he doesn't have a hat we're going
to stop and get him a hat
for sure don't do anything stupid get
pulled over you know what i mean
i don't know anybody poking around back
here
[Laughter]
hey charles eyes on the road and hands
at 10 and two you know what i mean
the boys are getting a little freaky
you've now entered the fully circle of
trust i hope you're aware of that
thank you guys yeah thank you so much
and also while we're at it we have to do
the [ __ ] honeymoon getaway yes
we're doing we're doing i think in a
week this week we do um
yeah bam that patreon is cooking shout
out to [ __ ] patreon we [ __ ] love
you guys
we love you once tebow gets back we'll
be back on track and cooking and cooking
and cooking and booking cooking and
booking
uh all right this one's from jay we have
touched on it before
and then this is a we can tie this in
with another question is it trash to
wait for and we've talked about is it
trash for the wait for the cashier
hold on is it trash to wait until the
cashier is looking at you to put the tip
in the
in the cup or wave the money at him when
you put it in
you got to make eye contact you got to
strategically do it i did it this
morning
and you got to [ __ ] what i do is i'll
say
thank you as i'm putting it in right
like okay
thank you otherwise why do it
for them i ain't doing it for them i'm
doing it for me and the people behind me
that see me doing go this guy's probably
got a couple of bucks on
right you don't want to feel like a
piece of [ __ ] sure i want to look like i
got money
and from being on the other end of that
if you don't
see a tip your attitude's a little bit
different
well i did it this morning uh me and my
buddy wanted to get some fresh bagels
not too shabby is it the thing because
when you have the the ipad
they don't really see it which is for
okay beep
beep it's bad enough that ipad those
those coffee shops are getting
real [ __ ] dicey with what they starts
with 20
20. i'm like it's a [ __ ] what are we
doing here
a dollar maybe a dollar but it's summer
like and they don't even
really five seven dollar tips i'm like
it's a cup of coffee
[ __ ] cup of joe's costing me nine
bucks all this to my cardiologist that
you're getting [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm telling you kidding me
um you gotta see no it's not trash it's
not trashy you know you want to be
rewarded
hey man thank you very much yeah awesome
it's more
for me to feel better and it for me it's
i want the other people to see me
tipping i want to make it look like i'm
[ __ ] what's trashy is when someone
makes
change out of this i've seen that you
ask
hey can you give me back someone you
know like if and let them do it but i've
seen people go in there and dig oh
no [ __ ] dirtbag yeah yeah yeah also
the one that
we went this morning i [ __ ] i i hit
him and she stopped saying thank you the
last two times i've been in there
and today she didn't say thank you again
i don't know when you hit her even when
i hit her
she knows she saw you she saw me i go
thank you very much and she doesn't say
nothing [ __ ] her right yeah that's the
same place where the guy doesn't [ __ ]
give me the i think we talked about hard
feelings mum's the word when i go in
there with the one [ __ ] guy
avoids eye contact the whole time yeah
it's no good it's no good
they make a hell of a [ __ ] bacon egg
and cheese those baggies are toy
i'm toasted by the way look the other
way um
[Music]
all right here let's see that goes back
and also the same place this is from
mark quick question is a business that
only sex
accepts cash in 2021 classy or trashy no
it's usually [ __ ] a knockout
[ __ ] fantastic [ __ ] restaurant and
they do it so good
that they can only they can yeah cause
you'll keep [ __ ] coming yeah
shout out to divernica clydis that's the
[ __ ] the bagel place i was talking
about this morning cash only
and i've you know i [ __ ] it's that
good i'll go do that peter lugar's wait
it's cash only yeah
where i just had the bagel place that i
had a bagel place
yeah we got it i wish i were taking a
limo
what flip it was good right yeah bagel
please fish only
wow they keep they keep you coming back
dogs damn that steakhouse is [ __ ]
[ __ ] like that holy [ __ ] yeah
what's the name of this joint like fort
washington bakery in delhi or something
that lied to me it's called paisanas
um lugers gets away with that you see
there was just a shooting at luger's
crazy nuts two guys shot lugas
i can't see how they could be they were
shot with a ruger
i can't see how they were there can be a
fight in there because there's a lot of
people that go in there that [ __ ] i
don't know what happened at all i'm
talking out of my ass
it was a fight within the same party it
was a party of 11 were there for like a
birthday
two people in the party together that's
garbage god
dude if you're showing up to dinner to a
family dinner with a [ __ ] piece on
any fight at a family party is trash hey
stay away from the
stay away from the sullivan family
christmas will ya there's always a
couple of [ __ ] donnie brooks
you never loved me yeah all right let's
uh we got one or two more here and then
we got to go
uh we have like one
this is one of more of advice a little
bit a little bit of at least
yeah i mean you know all right he goes
me and my fiance were reminiscing about
being nothing on that dear kippy come on
right in here sorry
say it again dear kippy oh this is great
i love that thanks buddy
um me and my fiance were reminiscing
about being bored in church as kids and
she tells me about how her mom would
clip her fingernails during the morning
sermon
as i pick myself up the floor she lays
another whopper on me
who's tall what are you in the 50s
delays another whopper on me by telling
me that she didn't catch the nails in a
napkin or anything just brush them off
onto the floor like a complete psycho
that dna is in my future wife should i
call it off or what
it ain't good you got to keep her on a
short leash when it comes to
cutting your nails in church the mom was
doing it yeah this broads mom
she the mom wasn't doing it to the kid
no the mom was doing it to herself
i don't think i've ever seen my mother
clip her fingernails yeah i thought
broads get them done
yeah was she a farmhand or something
what the [ __ ] going on
you go to the nail place to get them
done i don't know that's weird man
clipping your nose in public is
atrocious house of god
yeah you can't come back from it and
then put them maybe if you're bored and
you're doing it by anxious you peel it
off and you i'll put it in a pocket
or something until i'm like i can't let
somebody watch me throw a fingernail
on the floor of [ __ ] god's house you
know what i mean i do it pretty
regularly in public though
i'll bite him and yeah it depends where
i mean
it's clipping who leaves the house when
you're getting your keys your wallet you
get a [ __ ]
nail clipper oh you ever see somebody
that has one on their keychain
trash no if i i wouldn't i would not
associate with somebody that rolls
around with a [ __ ] nail clipper
on their keychain that's a tough look
not happening all right uh let's do one
more and then we got to get out of here
guys home runs [ __ ] question so far
fantastic um
we did scissors let's see let's see
i was jumping around too much i'd like
to know what your system is over there
well you know we field a lot of the
questions and then i have to
uh kind of as it's going on i gotta go
oh this one will lead into that one
i kind of pick and choose a little bit
you know what i mean i'm developing i'm
hosting the show i'm doing there's a lot
of
it's like a duck who's cruising there's
a lot of work going on there's a
quarterback i'm quarterbacking the thing
yeah
you i you think you're hosting meanwhile
kippy's calling the shots okay i didn't
know that's what you were doing
yeah um this one's just nuts and what
we'll get out of here on this
um are you garbage if your father brings
in a live turkey to her elementary class
show and tell with the turkey legs tied
together in an old pair of your mom's
nylon so the turkey couldn't run away
why the [ __ ] are you bringing a turkey
because they're hillbillies what do you
mean
these aren't i mean it's not even
illegal turkeys don't [ __ ] around
that's why their [ __ ] feet are
wrapped up in the nylon dude i'm calling
in sick that day
yeah what the [ __ ] that's nuts dude
that's all his name is patrick patrick i
want to know where you're from
bringing any animal into school is trash
would you ever do a show-and-tell
uh i've been to show-and-tell
[Laughter]
shout out to it shout out to show and
tell down there
on columbus boulevard in philadelphia 18
to enter
byob clean living
um yeah i've done show-and-tell i
brought my dad in a couple of times
to tell like navy he was a fatter
version of me to tell navy stories
back in the day talk about knob and [ __ ]
lowers the lights
lights are sick i had an uncle do that
shout out to my uncle larry
jacked up the korean kid yeah he went in
and told some stories at my brother's
like hoity toity [ __ ]
holy toy private school i don't know if
he was i don't know if he was asked back
the next
year he was [ __ ] cranking more breads
[ __ ] these mainline bozos didn't know
what hit him
you could smell the blood a mile away
yeah um of course i've done [ __ ]
show-and-tell
all right man we're not a turkey
nobody's bringing them these are my
these are my seashells [ __ ] hit the
bricks fatty
this is megatron he's a bad guy
yeah [ __ ] like that yeah yeah uh have a
[ __ ] real snoozefest you were
here's here's something that really
[ __ ] threw me for a loop
when i was probably in third or fourth
grade we had this kid
that that was in our class that for show
and tell
he brought his dad in and his dad had a
hobby
of making this was the hobby he made
clay figurines of
civil war of civil war battles
that's what they were they were like
soldiers fighting soldiers
and they came the one guy had his head
like the head was gone
it was like real gory it's a catholic
school too
and to double down on the weirdness they
did like a little
like a little bit where like they both
spoke in like a like a southern accent
and this and that
oh dude no way yeah that kid didn't get
invited at a birthday party
he ain't coming he ain't coming to the
skating party [ __ ] bad shirt didn't
i always looked at dads with hobbies
like my one buddy's dad used to fly
those
uh like the mini versions of airplanes
no
like the rc airplanes no like go out on
a saturday and do
that swearing a fighter that's [ __ ]
cutting the grass having a beer like
you know man it's either you're working
you're working at that you're working at
work you're working around the house
or you're [ __ ] having some michelobs
that's what you're doing
that's all that dad was allowed to do in
the night yeah i don't like hobbies yeah
i remember i dude i remember one people
one more
kid we we played hot we were hot on a
hockey team and the dad would play
hockey with us and i remember being like
how did who respects this man
he had a [ __ ] this guy's all rollers
this guy's on rollerblades wait what are
you zipping around with this wait hold
on he was the coach
but like at practice but you were an
actual team yeah
of roller hockey roller hockey and i
said we played roller hockey in the
summer or like you know
winner would be roller hockey regular
hockey i respect
a roller hockey team come on you're
basically a cheerleader at that point
what are you doing and why would he play
with you
he would like for practice or whatever
like he would
strap up his skates and zip around with
us
and i remember being like dude [ __ ]
why don't you learn how to [ __ ] work
with your hands creepo
[ __ ] why don't you go to chi
institute become so you know
learn become an ac tech or something go
get a laptop and [ __ ]
do something man what are you doing
you're embarrassing us
no no way no way would i ever be able to
[ __ ] have that no
that's trash all right we gotta wrap it
up gang we love you
thank you for tuning in kippy what do
you got for him um i'm at kevin ryan
comedy on social media
uh as you know patreon subscribe you can
subscribe to patreon
itunes uh drop us a review that helps
with the algorithm and [ __ ] like that
subscribe on youtube
uh full video available on youtube every
every episode and also guys our live
show is coming up
we got to move some tickets we got to
move some tickets in indy uh that's
coming up in june
ac is probably going to [ __ ] it by maybe
sold out 18th down in atlantic city or
it's going to sell
tickets now not many left chicago we
added a second show i'm pretty sure
that's probably already sold out if not
very close so get those tickets
but uh guys will be in indy so if you
live near indy i think dayton's close to
whatever
indianapolis indiana get some [ __ ]
ticks come hang the live shows have been
a [ __ ] hoot we'll see today
yeah we love you so we'll see you next
week thank you for your patience we love
you bye